thursday edition p-f-t-o-t the time that
we can get into things we didn't have
time to get into during pft live and
since you and rodney harrison were
spending so much time coming after me
for my picks of the best number two
receivers in the nfl we didn't have time
to get to this
the new look for the washington football
team they've given us a glimpse of what
the helmet's going to look like with the
logo gone with the numbers on the side
oversized numbers in that yellow that
they have on their face mask and on
their pants sometimes
i
this is gonna work right they kind of
stumbled and bumbled their way through
this offseason dealing with the name
getting rid of a name that had to go
getting rid of a logo that had to go
trying to find a new name not being able
to handle the legal side of things in a
timely fashion coming up with a
placeholder that i think is going to
take root and people are going to like
and i like the uniform i like the name i
like the dynamic it's different
and uh
there's just something about it that
works even though it's just the result
of one mistake after another chris yeah
well you know sometimes it's better to
be lucky than good as they say right and
i mean this is one of those instances
first off i'm a sucker for numbers on
the helmet you know whether it's alabama
writing college football that just looks
good right there damn that's landon
collins i believe number 20. i mean
i mean it's got it's a good color
combination and i like the big oversized
numbers it's cool this year we got the
chargers and the washington football
team going to have numbers on their
helmet and uh you know as far as
washington is concerned i've always
loved their uniforms i've loved the
color combinations i think they're very
unique uh but
i i as time has gone on
and and really we never really got to
discuss this when it was first unveiled
i i never really had a huge problem with
this name the washington football team i
think it's kind of cool it's kind of old
school first off the w is you know it
looks good it's kind of old school and
it's look there you know and why do you
why do we need a nickname i mean why the
washington football team i think it fits
perfect for in the nation's capital
there's a team that yeah no we're just
the washington football team we see
soccer teams do it across the world and
i mean i can't even name you know
what's what's barcelona's nickname i i
mean what's real madrid's nickname you
know so i mean you can certainly pull it
off and still sell merchandise and
things like that
the one caveat that i would add to that
and let me just first say i agree with
you and i think if they make it to the
playoffs this year
they will keep the name longer than they
would have the the name that is no name
longer than they would have if they make
it to the super bowl somehow someway and
we've talked about the other screwy
seasons over the past 40 years 82 with
nine regular season games washington won
the super bowl 87 with the strike and
the replacement players washington won
the super bowl
uh if they would get to the super bowl i
don't think they're ever going to change
it at least not until the franchise
bottoms out and they feel like they need
to kick-start it again with a new name
my only concern is this chris yeah and
it's not an issue this year because fans
most likely won't be at the games the
problem is if you don't have another
name ideally two syllables beginning
with r
you're gonna have people that still
refer to them
loudly right as the name that is gone
especially when they sing the fight song
you can't sing hail to the washington
football team it doesn't fit so that
that's the one concern i have and and
you know good point i never thought of
that you're right it'll encourage people
and i could see daniel snyder seizing on
the fact that people like us are saying
hey we kind of like this
team with no name as a way to kind of
passive aggressively
finagle it so the team that is no longer
known by the offensive racial slur is
still kind of known by the offensive
racial slur to those who still want to
call it that yeah i i i never it never
occurred to me but you're right i think
it would keep that name probably alive
a little bit longer um and you're right
the ones who want to fight back against
oh you know cancel culture and there's
no such thing as racism in our country
even though 75 racist things happened
you know this morning but okay
uh yeah you're right that'll be an issue
so maybe that's why they can't do it
either way i'm excited to see how it
works out this year and how fans do get
around it a little bit you know like the
w even the way it looks right here on
the bottom of our screen it's just it
almost has like an old ivy league
football field i feel like it's like
we're back in like 1920 and we got a guy
announcing the game that here here goes
here goes haskins around the corner oh
there goes the champ oh they scored hey
like i feel like it look it looks like
it'd be one of those teams like that
that was a pretty good impersonation i
thought that's pretty good that wasn't
bad that wasn't bad
based upon
it's it's the only impersonation
impersonation or impersonation i've ever
heard you do that doesn't sound like
phil simpson right um it's like phil
sims after you took a shot of a helium
balloon all right um
here's the thing they can they can have
a name
and still use those uniforms you don't
have to i mean the alabama crimson tide
doesn't have a crimson tide whatever the
crimson tide is on their helmet they got
the numbers you don't need to have
anything on there just stay with this
uniform stay with that just keep
washington
and then you've got you know what
whatever name they would come up with
uh
that's your nickname but you still look
the same as you do this year i'm telling
you for as as bungled as this was this
whole remember when there was that
period of time where we're gonna get rid
of the old name when we have a new name
and then a couple of weeks later well
you know what we really don't have a new
name so we're just gonna go with this
for who knows how long
it's all landed in a spot where there is
something kind of cool about it how they
look and and this washington football
team thing
and uh you know however long it lasts if
they are competitive it's going to be
remembered as a special time in
franchise history especially if they
come up with a name to take the place of
washington football team so you know we
agree on this yeah there's and and it
just shows you this because people are
like oh you hate you hate the washington
football team that's why you're you're
coming after the name no the name was a
racial slur and they did the right thing
and finally getting rid of it even if
they did the right thing for the wrong
reasons not because native americans
were asking for it but because sponsors
put pressure on daniel snyder to do it
it has nothing to do with the team i
hope they do well i like ron rivera a
lot i've got a ton of respect for him i
think that just like with the raiders in
the afc i think football is more
interesting when the washington football
team is relevant yeah right and they
haven't been relevant for a long time
chris no i know yeah you know and you're
right they're not and that's what made
the 80s great i mean it's it's why you
know early 90s and all that i mean yes
washington to me is one of the
you know most precious franchises in all
of football and when i think of nfl
football they're one of the first few
teams i think of you know along that and
it you know i used to get chills at the
old giant stadium watching the redskins
at the time washington come out into the
come out of the tunnel with that uniform
and their mystique and you know winning
history and everything like that so it's
uh it'll be interesting to where it goes
the one thing i do i love that fight
song so i hope they can find a name that
can fit in there somehow because i mean
that is one of the cool traditions in
the nfl and again i'm so happy they
changed the name because it was
disrespectful and wrong and all that but
you know it is cool to be at a game
there in washington and then because
you're not used to that in the nfl to
hear a band start playing and a whole
stadium starts singing this song it's
pretty cool and i hope they can keep
that tradition alive
yeah and uh again two syllables first
letter r that's the way to do it and
we'll see if they can get that all
worked out for 2021 or 2022 or whenever
this year it won't matter because the
fight song is not going to be heard in
the stadium most likely all right that's
it for pft ot chris enjoy your long
weekend thank you always we'll be
thinking about you tomorrow i'm sure
we'll be in touch all weekend long and
uh we'll uh be posting all day long at
profootballtalk.com we'll be back with
another edition pft pft live tomorrow
everybody have a great day see ya
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports